modern trolls lurk about social media
harassing and antagonizing disguising
their identity and hiding in the dark
edges of the internet the namesake of
this bad behavior makes more sense when
you learn all about the early tales and
evolution of this creature
a nordic creature based in scandinavian
legend many trolls appear in the
icelandic sagas and originally the troll
was less a certain type of monster and
more a term used to refer to a variety
of monsters it was more about what a
creature did that made it a troll not
its appearance a lot like our modern day
trolls
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
before the 19th century troll was a
massively broad term
part of the reason it's so hard to
define a troll is that we still aren't
even sure how the word developed or its
original meaning the word troll in old
norse icelandic could have indicated
huge creatures giants and titans but
most likely just meant some kind of
magical being
in old norse it even has two forms and
both have a myriad of meanings but all
indicate malevolence
while in modern day stories trolls are
typically portrayed as lacking
intelligence ancient trolls were
actually quite clever the earliest
stories of trolls date back to 12 20 12
30 ce in snorri sterlison's prose etta
we find bragi the old a fictional
counterpart of a human poet of the same
name who lived in norway during the late
9th century and who had a chance
encounter with a female troll
braggy came across patrol while driving
some kind of sled or wagon through the
forest at night
instead of greeting the man with threats
of violence she introduces herself in a
poetic voice as moon of the dwelling
rugner giant's wealth sucker storm sons
bale cirrus's friendly companion
guardian of the corpse fjord swallower
of heaven wheel
the poet responds with his own
introduction and the encounter ends
by letting the troll speak first and
mirroring her speech the poet shows
deference to the troll indicating he
recognizes the land as hers
from her introduction we learn a few
things she's wealthy practices magic and
can bring about death and destruction
these traits would form the backbone of
troll mythos
this is just one troll tale of many
it should be stressed that ancient
trolls weren't a clearly defined being
in their earliest appearances in
folklore and legends a troll was an evil
paranormal being that occupied the space
outside of civilization and posed a
threat to living things within it trolls
often lurked at the boundaries of the
community as beings who inhabited areas
away from the farms and communal spaces
of humans
their presence marked danger and often
death they were anti-social creatures
that could be any kind of monster from
witches to vampires possessed animals to
ghosts
they could be large giants or diminutive
elves were often skilled at magic
hoarded gold and other treasures and
were incredibly strong
perhaps because of the early bragi
example and the general belief that
women were more skilled at magic female
trolls were considered particularly evil
another saga describes the female troll
augmenteur as the greatest troll and
monster ever born in the northern
regions of the world
this troll has a human head fangs a tail
and talons
she appears to be a more than proficient
fighter wielding dual blades and taking
out 60 men with surprising speed
she is defeated only with a magic shirt
and dwarf made arrow troll appearances
in early 13th century literature add to
the mutability of the creature
sometimes they were said to be smaller
than most children in other accounts
they could shape-shift into animals and
trees as well as non-living objects
trolls don't have to be humanoid in the
late 13th century poem the sybil's
prophecy which was likely recorded even
earlier a wolf is described as the
chewer of the moon in the guise of a
troll trolls can appear individually or
in groups like when in another old norse
saga two men of a king's retinue stumble
upon a mountain cave with a group of
trolls around a fire the trolls are
discussing their fears that the king
will attack their homes and drive them
away threatening the families and
cultures they are trying to protect
but still the narrator of the story
calls them demons
again this seems to be the general basis
for calling something a troll the threat
of violence as one 13th century poet
writes not much is worse than trolls
since the publication of the sagas in
the middle ages trolls have lingered in
the popular imagination most notably in
the scandinavian countries medieval
norwegian law even recognized the
existence of trolls between the 12th and
14th centuries laws made it illegal to
sit outside to awaken trolls in order to
perform heathenism or to call someone a
troll or a witch trolls can be helpful
fixing tools helping with harvest or
lending expensive goods
but often medieval trolls are
threatening
in part because trolls marked the
outside boundary of the rural community
beings who lived away from the farm and
communal spaces humans inhabited aka
so-called wild creatures in addition to
their tendencies to steal objects and
land another bit of famous troll lore is
their penchant for stealing people
trolls usually kidnap female victims
likely because nordic beliefs of the
time were that at certain periods in a
woman's life during childbirth or right
after it they were considered outside of
the church and therefore more vulnerable
but men weren't necessarily safe
in a 14th century saga a young man is
kidnapped by a hideous female troll she
is as small as a child but incredibly
stout with a long face crooked nose
black hair and a black skull
the man must kiss her despite her
dripping nose
when he wakes up in her bed he is
surprised to see his beautiful fiancee
lying next to him her troll woman's skin
at the foot of the bed the woman's
stepmother had turned her into a troll
with a curse but her fiance's kiss broke
the spell
and yes the story seemed familiar to me
too it seems like shrek has some
grounding in ancient nordic tradition
these early troll tales laid the
foundation but the 16th century saw the
biggest change in troll folklore
the mid-16th century marks the religious
reformation of scandinavia when
lutheranism became the dominant religion
during this period of religious focus
trolls were associated less with the
supernatural and more with the devil
although that connection would fade over
time and a waning belief in witches in
an attempt to quell the legends of
trolls and other supernatural creatures
a collection of christian hymns was
published in iceland hoping to replace
the pagan notions with formalized
religion
the text introduction states that the
unprofitable songs of trolls and of the
pagan peoples of old are in the service
of the devil and are of a heathen
tradition
this post-reformation period is also
when we see more stories about trolls
who wish to convert to christianity
in scandinavian and irish tradition as
well ferry and el flor includes stories
of the fae going to mass and
participating in christian rituals
trolls could become christians
even a malevolent beast could be
reformed
one icelandic folk tale goldbrow and
skagi and havamer tells of a greedy and
evil troll named gobra having set her
sights in a particular parcel of land
she uses witchcraft to appear as a young
and beautiful woman and tricks a man
into selling the land of his bedridden
boss arthur a well-known female settler
and political leader
who also just so happens to be one of
the few christians in the overwhelmingly
pagan country
the troll builds a pagan temple on the
land arthur intended to preserve as
sacred space
but gobra's success is short-lived
driven off the land goldbras attempts to
flee with her gold blindfolding herself
to avoid looking at the crosses that
would forbid her from leaving but when
her treasure tumbles the greedy monster
hastily rips off her blindfold and in
doing so is exposed to the crosses her
eyes are horrifically burned she escapes
but dies from the wounds
but death is no burden for our good lady
troll she rises as a ghost killing
animals and a couple humans behavior of
famous nordic pagan skeggy attempts to
stop his first battle against the troll
is unsuccessful and a few days later he
tries again this time he defeats the
troll and takes her gold but is gravely
injured
on his deathbed skeggy asks that part of
the treasure is used to build a church
because the pagan gods did not help him
in his time of need but the christian
god did by turning the troll to stone
despite their pagan association and
malevolent reputation trolls came to be
known for building churches
in a 1654 account of the construction of
lund cathedral by saint lawrence a troll
offers his services on the condition
that he would be paved with the sun and
the moon or the eyes of the saint unless
saint lawrence could guess his name
surprisingly the deal was struck the
lucky saint overhears the troll's wife
say the builder's name finn
upon hearing his name uttered the troll
grafts one of the church's foundational
stone pillars and tries to topple the
building
the saint averts the collapse by
transforming the troll his wife and
their child to stone
just like god had done to gobra if you
go to lon cathedral in sweden today you
can see a giant figure carved into the
stone
although scholars now identify the
carving as the biblical samson
given that saint lawrence was martyred
in rome centuries before christianity
reached sweden and you know the whole
troll thing
this story was likely fabricated to give
local context to the unusual carving
legends of similarly greedy troll church
builders exist in denmark and norway as
well if you ask me i believe that the
troll as builder legend was a way to
keep ancient nordic influences alive
post-christianity when stories were
introduced to try and reshape pagan and
ancient traditions
if i've learned anything from my
research for monstrum it's that cultures
will try to keep nods and winks to their
ancient monsters despite all the odds
other support for this theory is found
in an ancient nordic myth about the
building of a wall or palace around
asgard the home of the gods the man who
takes on the task asks for payment of
the sun and the moon and the goddess
freyja luckily for her the man is
tricked by the god of mischief loki into
not completing the task by the assigned
time
in his rage the man began smashing the
stones around him revealing himself to
be a giant a foe of the nordic gods
the thunder god thor kills the giant
with his hammer
like many ancient beliefs troll legends
began to fade as science progressed and
formal education became commonplace
that is until the folklore fascination
of the 19th century the famous danish
author hans christian andersen included
a princess taking a troll lover in his
first ever published fairy tale in 1830
marking the troll's entrance into
fantasy literature in 1852 the
t-r-o-l-l spelling appears in english
for the first time in benjamin thorpe's
scandinavian popular traditions and
superstitions
and around that time troll illustrations
began to accompany folklore and fairy
tales giving us some of the first and
lasting ideas of a troll's appearance
the very first illustration sketched by
johann frederick eckersberg in 1850 is a
hairy ugly bearded troll with a large
nose and honestly that's a foundational
image we still draw from
that same book by norwegian folklorist
peter christian as bjornsson is the
first publication of the three billy
goats gruff story where a long-nosed
troll tries to eat three goats as they
cross a bridge before being defeated by
the third and largest billy goat a story
that lives on today
another norwegian illustrator theodora
kittleson produced some of the most
influential and striking images of
trolls in the latter part of the 19th
century
his trolls vary in size and appearance
but their bodies always blur and blend
with their surroundings
implying that the border of the
supernatural and natural are nebulous
and perhaps giving a little nod to their
one-time shape-shifting capabilities
the middle of the century also marked
the first time trolls were taxonomized
into their own monster category
the first written collection of
icelandic folk tales was published by
john arneson and magnus crimson in 1852
arneson like many other folklores of the
century was influenced by the scientific
classification system that was on the
rise they attempted to divide the
supernatural into species and categories
he essentially divided elves trolls
ghosts and other monsters into their own
categories when before there had been
greater overlap especially when it came
to refer to a supernatural or evil
creature as a troll in 1867 famous
playwright henrik ibsen featured trolls
in pier gint and invented a new aspect
of troll lore the troll king
first performed in 1876 the play would
become norway's most performed play of
all time even today there is a pure
ghint festival every year
at the turn of the century 19th century
fairy tale trolls moved to novels
notably into science fiction and fantasy
in the 1950s j.r.l tolkien really
delivered on the troll in the hobbit and
his lord of the rings series one of the
most successful literary series of all
time
tolkien includes warrior trolls stone
trolls hill trolls cave trolls and
mountain trolls and fun fact in the
norwegian translation of the lord of the
rings gandalf the wizard is called the
troll man given that tolkien was both an
old english and old norse scholar i
think he'd be pretty chuffed about that
the fantasy tabletop game dungeons and
dragons released in 1974 included the
troll as one of its first monsters
further solidifying the image of a green
skinned troll in the fantasy genre we
also can't talk about modern trolls
without talking about troll dolls yes
those odd child-like figurines with
jewel belly buttons while the exact
origins of the first troll doll are
somewhat dubious it is generally
believed that thomas dom carved the
first wooden troll doll in denmark in
the 1940s post world war ii the dolls
became locally popular and eventually
dom was commissioned to carve a santa
claus for a swedish department store
the display also included elf troll
dolls
long story short everyone loved the
little things and in 1961 he mass
produced the crazy-haired plastic
version we now know and love or find
inherently creepy if you were me as a
child the immensely popular 2016
animated movie inspired by the dolls
introduced a whole new generation of
parents and children to the creatures
and made trolls popular again
but today trolls are always so fun and
colorful they appear in horror
literature and film often as threatening
monsters and as a manifestation of
foreignness
1986's troll horror comedy follows a
fairy who was forcefully transformed
into a troll as he uses magic to try and
eliminate all humans by turning them
into mythical creatures the 2010
norwegian film troll hunter alludes to
many of the old legends in a modernist
retelling where trolls have been forced
to hide in the woods by the norwegian
government
in 2018's fantasy romance border trolls
live among humans ostracized for their
looks behavior and inner sexuality from
nordic sagas to medieval law to those
ugly little dolls and of course hateful
online internet users who lurk in
comments trolls have been around for
more than a thousand years while they
haven't always looked the same the
malleability of their original
monstrosity has allowed them to endure
before you go i want to tell you about a
new documentary series on pbs voices
american veteran keep it close each
episode tells the story of a u.s
military veteran and a special object
they have from their time in service a
vial of lip gloss a small stone even a
microphone check out the link in our
description and let them know that dr z
sent you
no yeah too much
not enough
heathen
he's i mean heathen is okay creepily as
possible